so what I'm going to be talking about is
how to train image and text models
classification works faster with TP use
tensor processing units on Google cloud
primarily using ml engine which is our
managed infra platform but I'll also
show you how you can directly connect to
a TP you from your Jupiter notebook and
you can run things directly from there
as well so what exactly RTP use right so
TP users are essentially hardware
accelerators right mostly I think all my
career I've dealt with software but
hardware is this can cool thing right
that's out there and it we have been fun
basically getting to work with T peers
to basically the key thing about TP use
is that unlike most processors that we
are all familiar with this is not
general purpose software when we take up
CPUs you think of GPUs these are general
purpose you can basically do graphics on
a GPU you can do rendering on a GPU you
can do now gaming you could Bitcoin
mining you get a variety of things on a
GPU there's only one thing you can do on
a TPU machine Roenick right so it's back
it's up its up basic it's an
application-specific chip that's meant
for one specific task but what that
brings you is that it is the fastest
Hardware out there for machine learning
so there's the benchmark thing that's
run by Stanford called at dawn benchmark
and basically the TPU
reached like they have a desired
accuracy of 93% on imagenet how long
does it take to get to that and it's
basically reaches that in less than 30
minutes ok so what I'll basically what
to talk about here is I'll talk about
image and text models the two major
kinds of models that people train and
how you could do this on your own data
using our DPS okay so it also finally
talked about this final thing about if
you wrote a custom model
how would you adapt it so that you could
run on a TPU so I'll talk about why we
do NTP use how to develop with them and
then talk about state of the art image
models state of the art text bottles
and a spoon it said in the intro I
really get excited when people can do
this without writing any code or writing
minimal amounts of code so the two parts
about the state of the art models are
about how can you take something that is
bleeding edge right and basically just
go use it and finally I'll talk about
custom models and the custom models is
for the geeks who basically said no no I
want to I want to write my own I want to
actually do it myself and we talked
about how that as well
so first of all ytp use right why do we
why why do we go around and develop a
custom ASIC chip and we have three
generations of it already right but no
at least right we're not a chip company
why is it that we care and it basically
comes down to a few things that are
interesting from the AI development
point of view the first is this is a
graph that basically shows how the size
of your data affects error rate okay and
this is common to a variety of different
problems
this particular graph shows natural
language but whether you take images you
take time series you take text the graph
looks very similar the numbers are
different but the graph shape looks very
similar so what is this this is the
error rate and the error rate drops as
the size of your data goes up all right
fine but let's look at the drop it's
linear right the error rate is dropping
linearly but what's happening to the
data
what's the x-axis here exactly
exponential right between this grid line
and this grid line what's happening to
your data
doubling right so for every small
decrease in error rate when we say we
need a lot of data for deep learning
what are we talking about we're talking
about twice four times 8 times 32 times
as much data right we're not talking
about 10% more data we're talking little
small data right so that's a first graph
the second graph here is year-on-year so
Alex net which basically jump-started
the hole deep learning idea right with
eight layers and they basically know how
much compute
they need that some some level of
compute and neural architecture search
that is Google's Auto ml that's
basically go ahead and searching for
appropriate models using reinforcement
learning so that's the amount of compute
it needs and then alphago which is even
higher than that okay
so again this is every year and this is
the amount of compute that is needed and
what's happening to the compute it's
going ten times right so pretty much
you're on here so if you then put these
two graphs together it turns out that we
now need about three hundred thousand
times more compute that we needed just a
few years ago okay so that's the that is
the big thing that staring us in the
face
we need huge amounts of compute to be
able to get to better and better
accuracy and better accuracy is hugely
important right the reason we all speak
into our phones now is because the
accuracy dropped below a certain
threshold until it dropped below that
threshold they it wasn't good enough we
couldn't actually embed it into products
and now we can right and so it's hugely
important that we train these models and
we train them on our data with our
jargon with our industry jargon etc so
this is Jeff Dean who's like the lead of
AI at cocoa so in 2014 in at the back of
the envelope calculation and said if
everybody speaks into their phone for
three minutes will exhaust all available
computing resources on the planet so
what do you do you develop a TPU
right so basically the other thing to do
as well with Moore's Law save us right
you're on you're of course right
computing power keeps going up and these
are all the different revolutions that
have happened in computing with a number
of cores the different power and so on
and long story short it turns out that
pretty much everything has started
plateauing around 2010 it's a moore's
law is not going to
save us we need a lot more compute but
Moore's law isn't gonna save us right so
that's basically why it now is forget
about general-purpose processors if you
have a need for something that no has to
be developed then you go develop it
right if it's often enough so in 2015 a
year after Jeff deeds
back-of-the-envelope calculation we came
with TPU version 1 and remember what his
calculation was it was basically around
if everyone speaks into their phone so
what was he worried about was he worried
about training or was he worried about
inference inference so TPU version 1 was
about inference was about basically
making sure that our models that were
trained could basically handle the load
of all of our users basically using it
right so prediction the training can
take care of it softly thought let's get
the inference out so that was TPU
version 1 version 2 onwards it does both
training and inference so and then the
version 3 currently in alpha right it's
all all of these that we've developed I
mean the one of the things about an ASIC
chip is now you've got put in a lot of
investment to develop it so there's a
lot of incentive for us to basically
open it up for other people to use and
the way Google opens up for enterprise
users through Google Cloud okay so what
is the GPU this is basically the
schematic of what a TPU looks like ok so
you basically have two cores per chip
and each core basically contains a
matrix multiplication unit that's a
heart of it it also contains scalar and
vector units I'll talk about those and
it contains about 8 gigs of memory I'm
talking about a TPU version 2 version 3
has more memory it has 32 gigs but
version 2 has 8 gigs of memory per core
which is the largest kind of thing seems
tiny right why would you build a chip
with just 8 gigs of memory but it turns
out that it's not about this one core
it's about basically how many you can
put together right so per chip right you
basically have per core you basically
have no all of these things and you have
about 8
memory course the four chip four of
these chips per tip you each chip
contains two course so you have total of
eight course on it they are on one of
these TPU boards but then you take these
TPU Birds and you put them together into
a rack right and that's what we call a
part and a part has 64 TP use and each
of those TP uses four chips has to
course so that's basically getting the
power out there so great so you have 64
TP use per pod and the matrix
multiplication is where all of the power
comes in the idea is that you go look at
machine learning and what is all of
machine learning is essentially linear
algebra matrix multiplication so you
build a system that does matrix
multiplication very fast and nothing
else right and that's basically the idea
of identity to you I just do matrix
multiplication really really really fast
okay so the idea is to basically pack a
lot of power and density come because it
doesn't have to do anything else all
that does is matrix multiplication and
if we can do that the idea is it's a
fixed function architecture and the
earned brow if you were to think of a
CPU as doing scalar but a GPU of doing
vector math ITT use doing tensor Matt
it's basically and just focusing on
matrices and matrix multiplication okay
the second part of this and is is that
all of those chips they aren't
individual they're all connected by a
very high speed toroidal mesh and what
this essentially means is that they can
function as one unit so in either you're
not actually treating one core you
actually you're treating all of them
together so that's great right what that
actually means is that as you increase
the number of course the number of
images that you're processing or the
number of texts that we're processing
grows linearly this is a very very very
hard graph to get because this basically
means that we all familiar with it right
you distribute your code what happens to
your code it
doesn't scale linearly right it slows
down you're the fastest if you use just
one with the TPU the idea that one is a
part as long as you're within the part
is just as fast so you're basically
getting that high speed interconnect so
that you're getting the scaling that is
pretty linear for the number of course
yeah so all of those things we are
concerned about and those are optimized
but the blick every chip is optimizing
it right the key idea here is we're
focused on matrix multiplication and
we'll make sure that this thing will
we'll focus on the networking so that
this thing's case scales linearly it's
this it's I think it's a Google
philosophy right where don't do it on
one machine doing on multiple machines
scale them out and you get scale through
numbers it is that same philosophy of
the whole MapReduce ideas and all of
those apply to compute
I have no idea what the clock speed is
I'm a software guy I'm very good server
what I could get out of the TP use I
don't I don't I can find out if I don't
know even if we release them if we do I
can find out for you yes oh the Matt's
if there's a 64 TP use in a pod okay you
can go up to 64 you can also get
multiple pods but at that point the
linearity starts to break down right as
long as you're within a pod you're
basically getting this amazing network
once you're once you have a second part
it's not as much it yeah
and for you
right okay cool so we have a TPU so this
is why we developed the TPU how do you
develop with the TPU
right so that's basically now on to the
software side okay so first thing is we
are developing the TPU it's kind of
helpful to have a TPU that just attached
to your computer how do you attach a TPU
to your computer it's sitting there in
Google Cloud so what you do is then you
basically spin up a virtual machine in
Google Cloud and that virtual machine is
connected with behind the Google
firewall right to TPU so you basically
gonna basically have you know your cloud
tippy and you're connecting to it and
essentially what you do is if your CTP
your cloud tpo
up so if you're on if you're in cloud
shell or you can actually download the
CTP you program and you can install it
so you can basically do CTP you up give
it the name of the TPU and then from
your local machine you basically do SSH
into the cloud TPU with a port forward
basically i'm port forwarding port 8888
to my local machine let's open now when
then I start Jupiter with port 888 I'm
actually connected to the TP right so
anything that I run in that Jupiter
notebook is going to be running on the
TPU that's that is basically the idea or
I can run something on the TP so how
does that work so what I did was just
before we started the class I basically
they talked I went ahead and basically
did the CTP you up and I started Jupiter
so let me just go ahead and do Jupiter
here and at this point I'm doing
localhost eight eight eight eight and I
now have a Jupiter notebook and let me
go ahead and start a terminal and what
I'll do inside the terminal is that I
will do a git clone of
on my repo Google cloud platform
training data analyst all right so it's
been get cloned and I can go back here
and the repo showed up and let me go
ahead and pull up its notebook dpu and
so this is all on github
it's a TPU fundamentals so now I have a
notebook so let's look at the so this
notebook now when I run it right it's
running on this CPU or this VM that's
attached to the CPU so most of the stuff
is happening on the VM but if I say run
this function on the TPU to run that
function on the TPU so first thing that
I'm doing is that my name of my TPU was
locti PU so I'll do this and it was in
US central c so if i do that
demo gods
eight
this thing still running place it's too
reload it okay there much better okay so
let's run that and oh there is no I need
to change this it says there's no such
TPU so if I run that again so there it
is so that what I first thing I did was
that I said go ahead and find a DP you
with this name that's attached to this
machine so it now found that TPU so at
this point I have a TPU so let's go
ahead and say that we have a function
and very very fancy function I just want
to add x and y so have a function I have
that function and normally I would just
add x and y but what I'm going to do
here is that I'm gonna say go ahead and
call the add function passing in x and y
and run that function on the detail so
as long as you have a Python function
right as long as you have a python
function all that you have to do is
basically say TPU rewrite here's my
function these are the arguments it
takes run it for me and that function is
gonna run on the TP so that's
essentially what programming a TPU looks
like is basically writing some function
that is basically gonna get done so that
is a TPU ad and if you know how
tensorflow works that is created the
graph and if you want to run it I
initialize a TPU and then I say please
go ahead and run the TPU ad and we
should get the result of adding X&Y
right there X is basically numbers from
0 to 15 and I'm adding once to it so I
get numbers from 1 to 17 right 1 to 16 X
is 0 to 15 so I get 1 to 16 yes
this will also run in the Eagle correct
you can also do eager mode right now but
the eager mode makes it harder because I
want to do a TPU rewrite right so so it
makes it much easier if you're doing it
with this create the graph rewrite the
graph and then run the graph
yes the parameters have to be tensors
correct they have to be tensors and I
will also talk about ideally these
tensors have are huge and they basically
have bad sizes of like hundred
twenty-eight but I know I also because
that game it's this fixed function that
is the optimal behavior on it so as long
as you have the does that's essentially
it now we can of course take this and
put it together into something a bit
more interesting so what I'm doing here
is that I'm gonna basically get the M
nest data or hello world and then
basically create two numpy erase off of
that so that's basically what I'm doing
in this step and I'm downloading the
data and having gotten it I have X train
and white-white test and I then have a
function to do my fit my fit in my train
function so what I'm doing is I'm taking
the image that I get in and basically
flattening it out I have a 28 by 28
image an M nest
making that a 784 array and then get
take my weights which is a variable
taking my bias which is another variable
and then doing a very fancy logistic
regression model so x times W plus B
right that's my model and then my loss
so this is a one change that you have to
make so my loss is normally my
cross-entropy and my optimizer basically
optimizes the loss I can use an atom
optimizer but you don't use the atom
optimizer directly what you do is that
we take that atom optimizer and you wrap
it up in what is called a cross shard
optimizer remember what I said about ATP
you basically scales linearly with the
number of course the cross shot
optimizer is what does that right so it
instead of it optimizing either one core
it's gonna take this batch of images
that's gonna come in it's gonna spread
them out on
how many other calls you have and each
of the course is going to be is going to
do this optimization on us on it's part
of the batch and then there is a barrier
and everything hits the barrier all of
the gradients get averaged and then
you're on to the next step right
so the cross road optimizer is the one
change you typically have to make to
your code to basically take advantage of
this linear scaling so we do this and
then we say okay I want to go ahead and
optimize it so at this point then we can
basically say I want to take my fit bat
function and rewrite it TPU rewrite of
the fit batch function so my original
function would run on a CP or a GPU
rewrite it so that it can also run on a
TPU and run it for one step actually run
for fifty steps range of 50 and then you
basically get your loss so that that's
pretty much it so you can do iterative
development with the TPU attached to
your machine and you base almost like
now you're writing you writing a jupiter
notebook the way you're familiar with
running things within with the GPU is
it's very similar except that you now
have the the ability to scale this thing
out to really fast hardware and really
fast processing yes
which optimizes beside atom is supported
almost all of them right there may be
some and you can also take your own
optimizers and you can wrap them up
there's but we're getting disappointed
almost all of them intends to floor
support there's no there's some list of
apps that are not supported but as a
first approximation assume that it is
right and if it's not like holler yes
will this interface shift now this is
all this is TF not contributed TPU so
yes it is gonna change yes
but basically the way it works is
everything starts with contrib we get
the api's and everything correct and
then we fold it then this particular API
is not going to change much I think it's
just one function rewrite but later on
Manish when I talk to you about how to
do an estimator which is this higher
level thing that is going to change
significantly the idea being that out of
the out of the box we want our
estimators to actually work on a TPU
without you having to change your code
today because GPUs are new and the
hardware is coming up so no there is
this process by which you write your
estimator code and you have to modify it
you have to add in the cross-cut
optimizer those kinds of things
but we want to get to the point where
it's just automatic right you run on it
run on a TPU and this graph modification
just happens on that device before it
happens right does it so that's that's
our end goal we want to get there but
right now until we get there this is the
few changes you make but the part what
I'm hoping to say is that it's not this
magical thing these changes are very
minor you're essentially using crusher
optimizer and you're taking this
function that you want to write and
saying call it with a TPU rewrite that's
it yes can we use deep use with Kara's
yes right absolutely yes you can use TP
use with Kara's and your multifunction
can be any tensorflow function including
agarose function but you don't use the
inputs and outputs I'll talk about those
remember that the TPU does only one
thing and does one thing well which is
the mat so you want to make sure that
that math can be written in Charis
Charis on tensorflow it works yeah you
don't have to convert your Karras model
to TF layers no yeah it just works yes
no fight not currently yes
what about eager execution so that's one
of the things that's on the roadmap it's
something that we want to be able to
support but right now there is this
rewriting phase so it doesn't quite work
with that but the idea being that you
you develop with eager and then you
basically in production time you run it
on a TPU
is probably the more more acceptable way
to think about it so and no that's your
training and then again we have a
predict function and that's just a
traditional function and you want to run
it on a teepee you do teepee you rewrite
of that so again same thing so having
done that that will basically do the
prediction and you can you can plot your
prediction so but I didn't install my
plot like never mind okay so that was
that was the demo right and that's the
link to the notebook that I was running
okay so essentially you know follow
those steps and basically run run the
notebook and you can run it on on
Jupiter so all of my demos everything is
on github already so you should be able
to try them out okay so that was cool
so I showed you how to develop 180 tu
from scratch you basically have some
tensorflow function something and you
just want to run it but let's lick step
a little bit higher now let's say I want
to do a state of the art image mod right
well we could write it but why were you
writing it there resonate 50s around can
we just take a resonate 50 and run it
right and so now so there is a variety
of reference models available or for a
cloud TPU
so if you're thinking of image
recognition right you basically have
your resonate 50 101 200 etcetera
there's a variety of different resonant
models available ameba Netta that
pretty interesting choice what a me
Burnett is this is a neural architecture
search done on the image net with the
constraint that it should train very
fast on a TPU right so it is fast it is
accurate and it's trained on a very
large data set so amoeba net is a pretty
good choice if you're saying I want to
do image recognition right but resident
is the one that more people are familiar
with I'll just show you ResNet they all
work very similarly very interested in
the object detection Retina net if
you're interested in running things on
our own of phone mobile net or machine
translation I'll talk about the
transformer model right all of this up
transformer based and I'll show you an
example the exact time I'll show you an
example of of training something on your
own problem and the speech recognition
image generation they're more of these
reference models that are coming up all
the time they're all in this github repo
ok so if you want to go ahead and do a
state-of-the-art model it's all there so
let's look at how to take one of those
state-of-the-art models and just run
them on your own data so the one I'm
gonna pick
is the resonate 50 right so let's say I
only train resident 50 and that's the
one that basically was at the top of the
dawn benchmark and it's in the reaping
the report that I just talked about
Dan's referral slash TPU and there's a
models of facial resonance so that's the
model to run it first thing that you do
right how do you run it what I just
showed you was basically starting a TPU
on a compute engine that is useful for
development purposes do you want to DP
you attach to your desktop machine so
you can basically run things while
you're developing but now I want to
train resonate 50 on my large data
that's no longer development that is now
production and for production ization
you want something that is fully managed
the idea being you submit a job and m/l
engine starts up a TPU trains the whole
thing shoves the TPU down it's a
bandages the entire life cycle without
you having to start and stop it yourself
so all that you have to do is then you
onto the job you basically scales a
scale here is a basic dpo and see
basically specify the base the base gear
you can also do the cuban at this if you
are basically interested in having full
control over it so you can have a Cuban
ettus thing with cube flow and you can
have TP use as part of the kubernetes
flock I won't talk about that so demo
number two right so I want to basically
train or deploy ResNet on my own data
using a Mellinger so the links here
basically take me to a code lab how many
of you are familiar with code labs right
so a set of instructions that you
basically follow that essentially tell
you how to do it so the first thing is
to basically set up our environment so
this is basically telling you to do a
cloud shell and then convert so first
step is to convert all of our JPEG data
so I I will have data that I would want
to convert so let's see so okay the data
looks like this so I'm going to be
training on a data set of flowers and I
want to Train it to basically say these
are the flower categories in these
images the images all look like this and
the CSV file that I'm training on looks
like this
okay everybody can see right so it's
essentially the name of the file or the
location of the file or cloud storage
and the category okay so you basically
have a bunch of images each of which has
this is the file and this is the
category so you have that as a CSV file
you have a similar file for evaluation
so you have two files one for training
one for evaluation and that's all you
need
okay from this point onwards it just
follow these instructions train your
model okay so first step is to go open
cloud shell and make sure that these
things exist so I can go down here I can
go to cloud shell
and
do that and make sure that the the input
exists and the next thing is to find the
dictionary of labels and what I'm doing
here is that I'm basically taking those
files and doing a sort and finding a
unique of all of the labels to basically
make sure that I have the canonical list
of labels so do that and so there those
are the five types of flowers in my data
set so that is now my dictionary and at
this point I'm ready to basically train
on the TP you now can I provide my JPEG
files and my CSV files to my trainer if
I were doing it on a GPU that's exactly
what I would do right I would write an
input function it would read the JPEG it
would train it and I would be done but
when you're training on a TPU there's
something to be very careful about which
is that the TPU is extremely extremely
fast and it's good at only one thing
what's good at matrix multiplication is
it good at reading JPEGs No so what do
we have to do we're going to do a
pre-processing we're going to take our
JPEG files or CSV files take all the
things and basically put them into TF
records right so instead of it reading
one file for every input then a bat if
you has a processor bat there does a
read all these files ins will be really
slow right the TP is gonna be sitting
there waiting for this input our input
pipeline to finish reading the data so
instead what we're gonna do that we're
gonna take all those files and basically
dump them into a single TF record file
so that we can read in a huge batch all
at once and that way we limit the i/o
overhead that's being paid does this
make sense it's a first step let's
convert it into into TF records so to
convert those into T of records right
there is in
the TPU repo itself so tensorflow github
turn through flow TPU so in there in the
tools in the datasets there is a lot
it's a nice little program called JPEG
to TF record so we're just gonna run
that okay so it's gonna basically go
ahead and take all of our JPEG files and
convert them into TF records so this is
an Apache beam program how many of
you've heard of Apache beam beam ok beam
is this is a distributed execution
environment ready you basically write
your code in Python and you can you can
run it on a variety of different runners
including flink and including spark but
also including cloud dataflow and GCP so
what I'm gonna do in the next step of
this is that I'm gonna basically take my
code and run it ok run this
pre-processing code and at this point
it's gonna shoot this code off to the
cloud it's gonna get distributed onto a
bunch of different machines it's gonna
process all of this all these files and
create tensor flow records and then we
can train off the transfer flow records
this is going to take a little while
because it has to process all this data
so I'm gonna do the Julia Child think
I'm gonna say I put that at the oven
here it is it's already done right so I
already have in my cloud storage bucket
I hope I have in my cloud storage bucket
training the most ml there should be the
the pre-processed data is already
present so there is there it is flowers
and in there okay it's my pre-processed
data somewhere anyway it's there so what
I can then do is to basically go ahead
and do G cloud ml engine ok pointing at
the code which essentially comes from
the repo right that I just showed you
saying that big please go ahead and run
this on a teepee you
using tensorflow version 1.8 because i
was when i tested it on and with these
many images so this is the one thing
that you have to change figure out how
many images you have and pre-process it
run it you have a trained model and then
once you have your trained model you can
deploy it on ml engine you can deploy it
anywhere you want and then you can just
invoke the model it's just a Python
program and you should basically get
back the classification it's sending a
jpg file so when you're invoking the
program you don't need tensorflow
records they'll just send in a jpg file
you get back the classification so
questions so bottom line then
state-of-the-art image model pretty much
all done right so essentially run a few
scripts take your data make sure your
data isn't that CSV format write name of
the file category and follow the code
lab and you should have it done yes
we don't actually expand on the JPEG
image as a JPEG images in the pencil
flow record remains compressed it
remains the JPEG bytes data what the
only thing that we are doing is we are
taking the JPEG bytes data that's in
those files and instead of it reading
individual files it's gonna read one TF
record it's gonna get a thousand of them
along with the label right so it's good
that's essentially what what we've done
we basically minimize the amount of i/o
hit that has to have this man yeah it's
it's not uncompressing the data
yes exactly it is yes absolutely as you
pointed out even though you have to do
this conversion it is so much faster
because you do the conversion on the
ones but you train so many epochs read
rather than doing the conversion seventy
five thousand times because you're doing
75 thousand no whatever you get to do
the conversion on the one so pay the
penalty once and that and that penalty
also you don't have to do you can scale
it differently you can run the dataflow
job on fifty machines where you may be
training it only on two TP use so
instead of you doing this thing on 16
cores you now suddenly did it on many
more cores because a cheap CPUs are
cheap so do it on a lot of sea leaves
so I let's flip from state-of-the-art
image model so you want to train an
image model pretty much they take the
cord run it on your data and it's
strained right so you basically the
choices that you have to make are
essentially how big of an image model do
you want do you want resonate 50 or
resonate 18 or ResNet 120 something
right depending on the number of images
you can go deeper and deeper right so
that's essentially the only thing that
you might want to do you might want to
hype a parameter qunit and that's fine
as well right all of these models
support hyper parameter tuning so you
can basically say don't just train the
model once train it with all these
different parameters including the depth
of the resonant modeling so let's change
a little bit and say how would we do
state-of-the-art
text models unlike image models with
text it really matters right you can't
judge an image is a consistent format
everything is the same you just
basically know you're training you're
training an image partly just training
an image model good text there is some
difference or some things that you have
to deal with
so basically when you're doing there are
text models the modern-day text models
essentially consists of four steps they
do an embedding where they're basically
taking all of those words and converting
them into numbers into vectors the
second thing they're doing is that
they're now encoding these using an LS
TM right and then while you're training
you're basically shifting the attention
right during that sentence to basically
focus the the alastair model on a
certain length so that it learns to
basically expect what's going to happen
there and then finally in this
combination of this embedding it in
coding and then attending and then you
have the prediction phase where you're
basically predicting the next word of a
sequence but you're predicting that in a
conditional way and then you're playing
a beam search during prediction to
choose among those different
possibilities so you have to basically
write those models and deservedly these
have this reputation of being really
hard to train and really hard
right so it's really really cool that we
have a library to answer to tenser which
basically provides this best of the
breed language model and luckily enough
it also runs on a TPU so let's but
unlike images it's not just scripting we
have to do some work here so let's talk
about what kind of work we have to do so
let's say we want to basically write a
machine learning model to complete our
lines of poetry
so given this line we would like the
model to do this is a model going to do
that no obviously not right the model is
going to do something but the idea is
basically have it create plausible next
lines and how do you train a machine
learning model to create a plausible
next line of poetry
what do you train it with real points
you trained it with real points so what
am I gonna do I'm gonna go look at all
of the points that I can find I lay my
hands off in Project Gutenberg and
basically slurp them all in and my input
is gonna consist of one line and my
output is gonna consist of the next line
that's my label and I'm gonna basically
give that to my model and say this is my
input this is my output text input text
output tray fair enough so in order to
do that what we do is that we write a
problem
and the thing is that I recognize that
my input is text and my output is text
so what I have is a text to text problem
intense returns so I have a text to text
problem and I'm calling mine a poetry
line problem because I'm predicting a
line of poetry and then I basically
specify how many words I want this model
to remember now I thought it would get
lots and lots of times but it turns out
people don't write that many poems so
all i
altom utley ended up with was about
sixty thousand lines of poetry so it
wasn't a very big data set so I had to
kind of limit my vocabulary here right
so I did to power 12 words just learn
the most common 4,000 words in this
poetry database right so
that's the size of my vocabulary and
then I need to write a generate samples
function got given the data directory
it's going to basically yield a
dictionary that consists of two things
the input and the targets it may case
the input is a previous line and a
target is a current line fair enough so
that's essentially what that's code I
write basically saying that what my
vocabulary like what kind of problem is
it text effects problem and that I want
to read in something I want to write out
something and then I basically they go
ahead and generate data for me so this
is the game very similar to what I had
to do in images I don't want my TPU
sitting there basically reading right up
20 line poems everywhere I want to
basically create this data in such a way
that my input output overhead is
minimized and so what I'm doing is I'm
basically running this data gem for
point yeah this is the problem this is
my data directory right so basically go
ahead and read it and write tensorflow
records for enough and the reason it can
do this is because I told it given my
data files how do I create my input and
my output from a machine learning model
really when you think about it that's
all it needs to know how do I create my
input how they expect the output and
then it basically slurps through all of
you all of those all of the data that
you specified in this directory and
creates a tensor flow records once you
have the tensor flow records we are
ready to train the model but then I
realize that hey my model isn't going to
be great it's not going to be great
because I don't have enough data
remember that first graph I showed you
how much data do you need for a from
scratch model hey typical you know the
10 standard thing by default is set up
for English to German from all of this
all of the speeches ever given at the
European Parliament or something right
so humongous humongous data set and I'm
gonna give it sixty thousand lines of
tree it's not gonna be big so what I
want to do is to basically make the
model small so what the so this is my
hyper parameters I'm basically saying
just use two hidden layers just use 128
nodes in them and filter them with five
512 and my attention heads how many
words do I look at at any point of time
look at only four words at a time and do
a lot of drop out
what does drop out do it drop out shuts
down the neurons right and the basic
idea is it limits overfitting the
smaller your data set the more dropout
you need right so because my data set is
so small I'm going to basically increase
my dropout and I'm going to slow down my
learning rate okay because I don't have
great amount of data so use the lower
learning rate and that's per half of
parameters so other kind of like small
tuning that I do to my model and at this
pump from point I can just do go ahead
and train it okay and the model is a
transformer model and I'm having hyper
parameters that is transformer poetry
because that's the name of my Python
function that returns this hyper
parameter set so I'll go ahead and use
that hyper parameter and run it on ml
engine with one GPU or run it on ml
engine with four GPUs or eight GPUs or
whatever if I wanted to run this on a
TPU kind of wasteful because this is a
small data it it trains in now a few
hours on a GPU but if I said I want I
don't want it to train in 20 hours I
wanted to train in 12 minutes I would
race at least flip that remove the GPU
part and add minus - are you sleepy and
that's pretty much it
now that then what
transformer is gonna do underneath is if
this flag is set take this thing that
I'm doing and give it to TPU rewrite
that's all it's doing right underneath
it's basically quality - you rewrite
with all of the code that's already been
written
fair enough it you can specify you can
specify how many how many cores you want
let's see I don't know if it's still
running okay but it that that is a cool
thing I for a while I had it running
poetry let's see never quite I think all
ml poetry
nothing is still running so that was a
blog post
and there was a link somewhere in there
I don't never shut it down but if it's
not okay okay so give me a line you I'm
sorry
when we meet again we trim it again okay
so again it's not going to give you the
exact same no for him you want it to be
a different point so this is a no App
Engine thing so it's gonna no one's run
it for a while but it should come back
in a couple of seconds let's see what it
does a water by a strained sweet soul
poetic at least let's do this let's take
that line and make it do the next line
to it we asked each a song uh that is
terrible poetry okay let somebody give
me another life the woods are lovely
dark and deep some Robert Frost
efficient arrow here Oh yet long yet
long not died and views on how long
delays that sound pretty good
yes
can can it look at a picture and do a
poem absolutely
that would be an image to text model and
you can train it as long as you have
enough of a data set of images and
images and life I'm sorry have I done it
no I have it I don't again it was it was
easy enough for me to think of Project
Gutenberg and going and getting lines of
poems and training it so as before this
thing is this no I don't want to lose
track of the fact yeah it's a fun thing
but this notebook is also available on
github so you can go look at it you can
try it out try running it you can run it
on a GPU run it on a TPU right and all
of the code is there go ahead and please
do try it out
so last bit custom models okay so we now
know how to create an image model yep
just take an image model take it take a
text module we know where to go find it
and how to run it the last video I want
to talk about is how but if you wrote
your own custom models and I'm gonna
assume that you wrote it using estimator
if you'd ordered with Kerris you would
basically do a Karass after the model
you do Kara's model to estimator and you
will get an estimate route so it's one
function call on your Kara's model after
you give you model that compiled and
then you do model dot to estimator and
you have an estimator so the idea is
that now you want to basically run this
on a TPU so what do you have to do you
have to enable nerve replication how do
we enable replication the cross run
optimizer business right we also want to
avoid post latency how to be a white
host less latency converting to T of
Records put them all in one place you
want to do static shapes now that's
something we didn't quite talk about we
said we had a matrix multiplication unit
what does it work with it works with
matrices of a certain size if you want
to go multiply a three by three matrix
it's kind of wasteful right so what
would what were you gonna do is that
we're going to basically bring in a huge
matrix to multiply and that matrix is a
systolic array it cannot be this
variable shape
to be very aesthetic shaped so what
we'll do is a normally intensive flow
programs we read bad sizes with a
question mark in the shape we won't do
that in a teepee you program we will
have static fixed shapes normally it's
not a problem but if you have things
like language models for example you
might be padding each batch differently
based on the longest sentence in the
batch that's not going to work you have
to pad it to the longest sentence in the
corpus okay so yes this restriction is
because of the D because the fact that
the speed-up happens because of the mxu
the matrix multiplication right and the
matrix multiplication it's a systolic
array it requires a static shape so that
it can optimize the speed so you would
have to do padding of the dancers so how
do you do this well what you do right is
you basically use the TF data API to
read your data and when you're doing a
TF data rate API during training you
repeat forever
so that you never have any left over
badge batches all the batches are of a
specific size and then you read TF
records we talked about that right you
read T of Records don't read anything
else and you basically go ahead and do a
you know parallel interleaf so you
basically read them so that every worker
gets its own copy of the data okay and
when you do your pre-processing etc you
do them in a parallel punch so you call
the prefetch and then you make sure that
you always have static sizes so if you
have an evaluation data set that is 315
and you basically want to make it
divisible by 8 you dropped at 3 images
or whatever right so you do that and
then you make sure that the first
dimension is your bad size okay so you
transpose you input if necessary ah
right and then you basically make
anything that has a question mark in the
tensor flow shape you actually give it
the actual
so this is basically what this does it
basically sets the shapes anything
that's a partial unknown you set the
shape and then you basically create a
TPU estimator instead of a regular
estimator spec again I'm running through
this but just we've tried to make the
deck available so you wouldn't get that
okay and then what you saw in May
Jupiter notebook you find the TPU with a
cluster resolver and having found the
TPU then you basically go ahead and you
train and evaluate the way you normally
do your train and evaluate okay with
this thing there's this idea that there
are some functions that you execute on
the TPU and there are some functions
that you execute not on the TPU in
general all your input and output is not
on the TPU everything that is on the TPU
is all the matrix lat
so in with most machine learning models
the model function is on the TPU yes yes
there is a TPU profiler so when you run
it it will tell you what fraction of of
the functions that are running on the
TPU are optimized for the TPU and what
function what percent aren't optimized
we try to shoot for about 70 percent
it's it's really hard to get to 100
percent when you try to shoot for about
70 percent and the more you move all of
the pre-processing all that stuff into
the input function and you leave your
model function pristine the higher that
fraction is going to get and finally you
save the model and the cool thing is I
want to save the model it's just a
normal model and you can serve it either
from a CPU or from a GPU or from a TPU
ok so you can export the model and you
export the model it exports it both in a
TPU serving format and in a GPU serve
requirement so you can serve from it
either one so all of these steps that I
just rushed through there no explained
in that blog post and there is a github
repo as well so that demonstrates about
that CODIS
with that I just want to only do a plug
we have this promotion going on we have
a bunch of training courses so on
Coursera if you go to Coursera that arc
slash next extend it don't tell anybody
that next is over just go there next
extend it and you will be able to
basically get a free I think one month
free ok so you can take any of our
Google cloud courses for a month for
free with that one with that link and
cool talk what courses there's a bunch
of courses that you can take any of them
for a month for free so that's the link
Coursera coursera.org slash next
extended
[Applause]
you
[Music]